new here at six o'clock for the first
time in a long time tickets for the Las
Vegas Grand Prix went on sale this week
but longtime fans say they're being
priced out Formula One hasn't been here
since the early 80s American Express
Early Access customers got first dibs on
Monday ticket prices higher than
expected in hotel rates they are
skyrocketing Ryan Matthey is live from
where the paddock and the main
grandstand is being built Ryan how are
fans compromising
what John Denise even the biggest of F1
fans say they cannot afford to go to
next year's race three to four day
packages going on sale this week for ten
thousand dollars per ticket at least up
to that amount so many say well maybe I
can catch a view from the street or if I
cannot rather I could go to a nearby
hotel to catch a view even those rates
they say are unaffordable the racetrack
winds down the middle and Eastern
portions of the Las Vegas Strip there
are six areas designated for viewing but
when American Express holders logged on
for pre-sale Monday the cheapest tickets
many could find started at two thousand
dollars each the lower end of the price
range was initially announced at 500 now
some fans fear they won't find tickets
that low instead many are choosing to
opt out or perhaps take advantage of
those coming in I jokingly said I should
just rent out the house and we can all
go on vacation and my dad's like that's
actually probably a good idea so I jump
on hotels.com the ones listed so far
were starting at 50 500 a night and
you're talking about a two bed one bed
hotel room that fits two to four people
I'm like I have a five bedroom house
what can I get per night during that
time if the hotels are going to charge
that we also compared hotel rates right
now to next year hotels do fluctuate
pricing depending on demand year round
but our comparison found in over 300
percent increase in average room rates
for racing weekend
now important to note this is all still
in just the pre-sale phase priority
interest they go on sale starting
tomorrow people on that list had to pay
a small fee to get on it and then on
sale for the general public goes on this
Saturday reporting live near Cobalt and
Harmon Ryan Matthey 8 News Now